[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام اليس الوضع في
ليبيا الان افضل 100 مره مما كان عليه
ايام الطاغيه بالرغم من كل القلاقل
الامنيه هل يحلم بعوده الطغاه النافق غير
اعداء الثورات ولاقي احذيه الجنرالات
اليس كل الدول التي خرجت من تحت عباءه
الطغيان عانت الامرين بسبب القنابل
الموقوته الذي زرعها الطواغيت قبل
سقوطهم الا تدفع ليبيا الان ثمن مخلفات
القذافي
القذره الم يفتح القذافي مخازن الاسلحه
قبل سقوطه كي ينتقم من الشعب الليبي
الثائر ويدفعه للتناحر
اليس حريا بالشعوب الثائره ان تمضي في
طريقها مهما رات من ماسي في ليبيا وغيرها
الا يبقى ثمن التغيير اقل بكثير من ثمن
البقاء تحت نعال الطغاه
كالقفز اليست منجزات الثوره الليبيه على
صعيد الحريه والكرامه اعظم بمئات المرات
من المشاكل التي تمر بها ليبيا
الان لكن في المقابل الا يخشى ان يحدث في
ليبيا ما حدث في افغانستان
والصومال الم يتخلص الصوماليون والافغان
من الطغاه لكنهم فشل في بناء دوله منذ
عشرات السنين الا يذكرنا التناحر بين ثوار
الامس في ليبيا بالتناحر الذي حصل بين
المجاهدين الافغان بعد تحرير افغانستان من
الرس الشيوعي واذنابه المحليه الا يحمل
الذين حلوا محل القذافي كل صفات الطاغيه
الا ينزع الكثير من المناطق الى الانفصال
عن الدوله الام بسبب التخبط في المرحله
الانتقاليه اليس حريا بالذين انتصروا على
الطغاه ان يتصرفوا
كالثوب
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على
الباحث الاكاديمي الليبي خالد الورفلي
وعلى الكاتب الصحفي خالد بن جقه نبدا نقاش
بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تعتقد ان ما يحدث في
ليبيا الان مخا طبيعي بعد عقود من الطغيان
70% نعم 30% لا خالد عمر بن جقه لو بدات
معك بهذه النتيجه بالرغم من كل ما يحدث في
ليبيا الان انت تعلم ان الخبر الليبي هو
الخبر الاول الان بسبب ما يحدث من قلاق
الامنيه في البلاد اه بالرغم من كل ذلك
ترى النسبه الكبرى من الليبيين ينسون كل
هذه المشاكل التي يعتقدون ان الاعلام
يكبرها كثيرا وان الوضع افضل من ايام
القذافي بمئات المرات كيف ترد بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
وبعد النسبه التي تتحدثون عنها او يتحدث
عنها الجمهور او التي شكلها الجمهور
المتابع هو نوع من الامل القائم عند
الناس سميه مغرر بهم بسميه وعي زائف زائف
يعني يعني لان الواقع اكبر من ان يختصر في
اراء الناس يعني اراء
الناس راي الناس اذا اخذناها بالاغلبيه صح
الاغلبيه دائما بالنسبه لي انا كمسلم
دائما على ظلال ا الاغلبيه يعني الشعب
الليبي على ظلال وانت على صح ما شاء الله
لا لا الشعب يعني الشعب الليبي اللي اللي
مبسوط
الان خلينا نبدا الحلقه بنوع من الهدوء
المنطقي لا انت لسه وكيل على الشعب الليبي
هنا يعني انا لا اقول الشعب الليبي انا
اتكلم على نخبه على مجموعه شاركت في
الاستفتاء انا اتحدث على مصطلح الاغلبيه
في اي كان في الديمقراطيه او في اي كان
دائما الاغلبيه على ضلال ولم ياتي فيها نص
قراني بالنسبه لي على الاقل كمسلم يقول
اغلبيه على حق يعني نلغي الديمقراطيه ونم
طبعا تلغيها طبقى تلغيها الديمقراطيه
لانها جابت نتائج وكوارث ومع ذلك كل
قضيتنا ليست هذه طيب قضيتنا ان امال
الناس
تتحطم عند اول تجربه لنصب السياسيين بمعنى
القذافي الذي تتحدث عنه الان انت وفي
البرنامج وغيرك يرحمه الله ويرحم جميع
اموات المسلمين معايا هو الذي عمل انقلاب
بغير قطره دم صحيح ثم جاء الذين عده
فحالوا الدماء الى الركب الان يا سيدي
الرجل هذا انتهى من سنتين ثلاثه دعونا من
هذه الاسطوانه القذافي ذهب الى ربي فل
يحاسب عن المول عز وجل انتهينا من هذا
الموال دعونا نتناول واقع بكل ما فيه من
سلبيات الذي وقع كارثي لسببين رئيسيين
اولهما ان اخواننا في ليبيا استعانوا بقوه
خارجيه لتسقط هذا النظام وعليها ان تدفع
ليبيا ثمن هذا بعدم استقرار ليبيا لان
استقرار ليبيا وعودتها الى حالتها الاولى
يؤثر على المصالح الغربيه هذا الاول ثانيا
ان اخواننا في في ليبيا ثقوا في لعبه
السياسيين ما هو السياسيين هم الكوارث في
المنطقه العربيه وانت عارف رؤيتي فيها ف
فهؤلاء قادو او اوصلو الى هذه الوضعيه
التي هي الان في سوريا يعني اسف في ليبيا
بلد تتجه نحو الانفصال اسف الانقسام صراع
دموي الى اخره ارواح تتساقط يوم وتريد ان
تقدمها انت كجنه او يقدمها الاخرين كجنه
يعني انت تشهد بالز
اها مع ه دع دع في غ اوك جميل جدا بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم ربي اشرح لي صدري ويسر
لي امري واحلل عقده من لساني انا ما جيت
هنا اتكلم في هذه الجلسه الا حتكلم باسم
الدماء وباسم الاشلاء وباسم صيحات الامهات
والزوجات الارامل والابناء الشهداء من
واحد 969 وليس من الان هذا ابتداء ودعني
اتكلم وارد على ضيف لعل الكلام اللي ذكره
في قضيه التغليب وكذا هناك كتاب للدكتور
احمد الريسوني اسمه نظريه التغليب
والتقريب دائما الاحكام في الشريعه
الاسلاميه وفي كل الاحكام في العالم دائما
تناط بالاغلبيه والكثره ولا والناظر كما
يقولون لا حكم له حتى من باب العقل وكما
يقول طه عبد الرحمن حتى من التكوثر العقلي
احيانا نحتاج الى اعمال المنطق هذا جانب
الجانب الاخر لما يقول ان القذافي جاء
قذفه الله في لظا ب ولم تكون هناك قطره دم
هذا اصلا بعيد عن الخطا اولا كانت هناك
استقاله للملك ادريس في اخر شهر
89 فاستغل هذا الظرف ومن ثم تقلد م تقليد
هذا الحكم الشيء الاخر ليست القضيه هو
استغفل الشعب على حين يغره واخذ الحكم
ولكن ما حدث بعد من اشلاء من الدماء التي
قتل حول 100000 ليبي سواء كان مقتول او
مفقود دعني نتكلم على قضيه النا الناتو
عندما جاء يا استاذ فيصل جاء بشروطنا ولم
ياتي بشروطه بدليل انه لم ينزل على الارض
عندما اجتمع الدكتور محمود جبريل رئيس
المجلس الوطني الانتقالي في امريكا وجاء
مع احد السناتو الامريكان وعرض عليه ثلاث
شروط وكان موجودين مع اشخاص قال تسليم عبد
الباسط الاصابي على اساس انه من القاعده
اعاده محاكمه المقرحي ورفض هذا الامر ثم
قال له تدفع
ضريبه تدخلنا في ليبيا فقال له بالحرف
الواحد انت تريدني ان ناتي بمرتزقة
وكنا سنذهب الىى قضاء الحج وكان الكابتن
اسمه ديفيد يعني غير مسلم كان يقول لنا
الان قاربت الاحرام قلت سبحان الله نستعين
بغير مسلم في الدخول في نسك مهم وهو الحج
مره اخرى كنت في صيام وسافرت وجاء وجاء
وقت الصيام وكان كذلك قائد الطائره غير
مسلم وقال لنا صوموا وصمنا لانه اخذنا ب
لا نقول انه غير مسلم ولا نستعين به الشيء
الاخر يا اخي كنت نتمنى من لماذا نحن لما
اسحه حقيقه وغطه تاريخيه ي انينها سارجع
بالتاريخ الى ايام مصطفى بن حليم دق باب
بيت مصطفى بن حليم وكان السفير الفرنسي
فدخل السفير الفرنسي في مربوعه او في مجلس
غير الذي فيها لان هناك شخص اخر لا يريد
ان يرى كان الشخص الاخر بن بلا كان يقول
السفير السفير الفرنسي كان يطلب من مصطفى
عبد الجليل تسليم بن بلا لانه يشرف على
تهريب السلاح ايام الثوره الجزائريه عندما
فقدنا الجار ذو الجنب والجار بالصاحب وابن
السبيل فقدنا الجيران وفقدنا العرب جانا
الناتو والناتو كما قلت جاء ب يعني لم
ياتي بشروطه حتى اسمح لي اللواء عبد
الفتاح يونس رحمه الله قال لا تجعلوه لنا
كثا ج على رؤوسنا وتكلم فيه واغلظ عليه
القول الشيء الاخر يا اخي متى جاء الناتو
الناتو لم ياتي الى بنغازي الا بعد ان
فقدنا خمس من طيارنا سمين والعق والصلابه
والور فلي وغيرهم الشيء الاخر شباب بنغازي
البواسل اللي منهم رف الله السحاتي ومنهم
الصلابي ومنهم اسامه بن حميد ومنهم بعض
حتى ما يعرف بانصار الشريعه هم الذين
دخلوا على هذا الرتل وجعلوه شذر مذر هذه
الحقيقه اللي ينبغي ان تعرف في التاريخ
حتى لا يزيف ولا يقال عننا ان توار ناتو
اصبر
اصبر باحترامي الاستاذ خالد بارك الله فيك
هو اعلامي من الدرجه الاولى ولكنه انه ليس
سياسي لماذا لان السياسي كما يقول ماتسي
تونج لا يغت بتعقيد الوضع لو والله
المواطن الليبي البسيط لا يعتقد بهذا
الوضع وتعقيده والله لو كان يعتقد ما خرج
17 17 فبراير لانه سيقول سياتي الامن
الداخلي والزندقه والدعم والجيش والشرطه
العسكريه وسياتي التحقيق والتعذيب وسنبقى
في بيوتنا السياسي المحنك لا ينظر الى
تعقيد الوضع باي حال من الاحوال وهذه
مغالطه كبرى حتى عن ليبيا وعن غير ليبيا
نقول ما تفضل به الاستاذ خالد عري عن
الصحه ثم هناك شيء اخر اسمح لي الاصل في
الثوره الليبيه كانت سلميه 100% والدليل
على ذلك السلاح ما حمل الا لرد الصائل
والدفاع عن المدنيين هذه مغالطه بعض من
الناس يقولها واريد هنا حتى لا ندخل في
قضيه الفنكوش ينبغي علينا مثل في فيلم
عادل الامام ينبغي علينا ان نحدد
المصطلحات يا دكتور لان العلم لا ياتي الا
بالتصديق الثوره الليبيه هي تغيير سلمي
شعبي يهدف الى اقامه النموذج المنشود على
ارض الواقع السلاح لم نحمله يا دكتور الا
حمايه على اعراضنا وحمايه الان بس باختصار
الان يحث ما يحدث الان كل مطمن ليست اولا
ليس هو تفضل اذكر هناك صراع ليست هناك
صراع ليست هناك جبهه مشتعله هناك اشتباكات
تحدث احيانا وليست
دائما ولها اسباب ولله الحمد والمنه يتم
حلها هناك في ليبيا 22 مليون قطعه سلاح يا
دكتور حط الرقم هذا بين عين وليست هناك اي
جبهه مشعره في ليبيا كلها عباره عن
اشتباكات بسيطه يتم حل حلتها يتم التعامل
معها بالامس القريب كان هناك مشكله في
بنغازي تم حلها وتسويه الامور الى ب خلينا
نجي عليه نقطه نقطه خالد تفضل تفضل سمعت
هذا الكلام 1 + 1 يسا 2 كيف ترد اه كيف
ارد اولا الدكتور جزاه الله بخير ادخلنا
في بعد تاريخي
وبعد لان هذه المسائل يجب ان تؤصل يجب ان
ت ندخل بالتاريخ
وتاصيل انت كنت تسمع التاصيل وعجبك ما انت
كنت تسمع في الصيل وعج ماشي بس باختصار يا
اخي بينتهي البرنامج على التاصيل بعدين
الرجل
يلك لانه التاصيل هذا هو المشكله هو
الكتور مع حق انا اولا اول مره اسمع انه
انه انه الاستعانه بالعدو الخارجي من اجل
اسقاط مسلم مبرره ومع ذلك كله دعنا لا
ندخل في التاريخ كل بكل ما فيه عشان نخرج
من التاريخ يا اخي انا ابن الحاضر استعان
ثوار ليبيا بالناتو استعانوا بالشيطان
الازرق استعانوا بالملائكه تخلوا عنهم
العرب خلو انفسهم الوضع الان في سوريا في
ليبيا وضع ماساوي بكل المقاييس ماوي
ماساوي الدكتور يريد ان يقدمه بصوره
ايجابيه هو حر هو ادرب اموره لكن انا
كمتابع كمراقب اقول الصوره ماساويه ام
ونتجه الى مزيد من الفتنه وقلنا ان السبب
بالنسبه لي انك يجب ان تدفع ثمن وجود
الاخر الكتور يقوللي والله قالونا
الفرنسيين رفضنا شروطهم حتى كان مرتزقه لا
ده انت تقبل رقم انفك ده انت في قوى
خارجيه دوليه لا نريد ان نسميها تحرك الان
ثور في ليبيا الى هذه اللحظه يا رجل قوه
خارجيه حتى الان حتى الان تحرك في ليبيا
حتى الان تتحرك في ليبيا يا رجل داخل
ميدانيا في ناس تبعل دوله كذا وناس تبعل
دوله هذا الواقع اذا كان الدكتور يريد
يتجاهله يغط عن
هذا امر يخصه لكن القول باننا نقدم ما قام
به الاخرين انا يا جماعه ل خليني بالوضع
الان لا لا لا انا قضيتي في الوقت الراهن
ليسوا توار ليبيا على حق في الماضي او لا
انا انا اصلت المساله قلت لسببين رئيسيين
قو تدخل قوه خارجيه وضحك السياسيين على
الشعب الليبي لانهم هم السياسيين هم اشكال
اخرى من اشكال القذافي اشكال اخرى من
اشكال الانظمه
الحاليه يعني انتقلنا من من مازق الى مازق
يا اخي يكفيني انا في في في الوقت السابق
ان ليبيا موحده ا يكفيني ان ان ان ان ان
الدعوه الاقليميه البرقه او غيرها او كذا
يريد ان ان يجعل دويله لوحده لم تكن
موجوده يكفيني انه يكفيني انه يكفيني انه
في
منظومه التعامل الدولي ان هناك دوله انت
لا دوله الان لا دوله جميل جدا كيف ترد
باختصار ايضا باختصار وبدون ما ندخل كثير
في كم نقطه مهمه جدا طرحهم عاوز ترد عليهم
بالتحديد قو خار ما زالت تحرك الوضع على
الارض اشكال ليبيا كانت موحده كان هناك
دوله كل هذا الكلام والوضع ماساوي وكارثه
نعم بالنسبه الىى القوه الخارجيه دكتور
فيصل انا سارجع بك الى بدايه الث بدون
تكثير بدون لا شيخ بدون
بدون سريعا اول ما دخل توار طرابلس الى
طرابلس واخذوا قاعده معتيقه هذا الكلام
مباشره من نائب رئيس المجلس المحلي اسمح
لي بس نزلت طائره فرنسيه اسمحلي لاحظ انت
تقول ثو ل ثوار طرابلس انت لا تقول ثوار
ليبيا لا عايزين نحافظ على المصطلحات انت
تقول ثوار طرابلس ثوار بنغازي وثوار اسحي
اتم
وا انا اتكلم الان في واقعه في طرابلس
يخبرني نائب رئيس المجلس العسكري لمدينه
طرابلس عند تحريرها نزلت طائره فرنسيه
تاتي بمعدات للمجلس الوطني الانتقالي نزل
من فيها بدون جوازات قال لهم اولا اتوني
بالجوازات بعض الاشخاص كان لا يحمل
الجوازات ارجع الى الطياره الى ان تاتي
المغادره هذه نقطه النقطه الاخرى عندما
يقول هناك دعوه لانفصال ليست هناك دعوه
لانفصال وانما هناك دعوه الى نظام اداري
هو بعض من بعض من الناس ولا اقول حتى هناك
كثير من الناس من يدعو الى الفيدراليه
كنظام فقط بل هم انفسهم على انفسهم
منقسمون يعني لا تجد لهم مثلا راس او لا
تجد لهم شخص او لا تجد لهم كذا نحن نقول
والشعب الليبي حقيقه هذه وجهه نظره انه
يتق في النظام الفيدرالي ولا لكن بعض
المتفضل لعل عليهم بعض الاشارات وهذه
القضيه ستحتاج الى معالجه اسباب هذه
الدعوه وانا شخصيا سالت اول من دع الى
النظام الفيدرالي وهو الشيخ الزبير
السنوسي الله يحفظه قلت له ما هي الاسباب
اللي دعيت الى ذلك قال لي التهميش كذا كذا
كذا كذا قلت له اذا انحلت هذه الامور سكت
يعني القضيه لو لو تجلس مع ليس انفصالا
ليس تفط ان هو نظام اداري وهذا سيتم وليس
انفصال ليس انفصالا ببت هذه النقطه طيب
خليك شويه خالد كيف ترد على هذه النقطه
ليس نض رد اللي عليها الرجل يقولك
الفيدراليه هي شكل من اشكال الدوله موجوده
الان في العالم نماذج كثيره الانتقال من
الدوله الجمه من الدوله الموحده الى نظام
فيدرالي شكل اخر تماما بمعنى انني انا في
في في في منطقتي الفيدراليه في ولايه من
الولايات قد اتصرف ب مواردي بما لا يخدم
الدوله ككل ومع ذلك كله ام الدكتور يطرح
نظام فيدرالي هذا هذا هذا اتجاه نحو
التجزئه والتقسيم هذه مرحله مؤدبه فقط
بدليل الناس انا كنت اقول للدكتور قلت له
ثبت حكايه ثوار مراطه ثوار طرابلس ماشي
خليني خليني هلق بالفتره لا بدون ايه نرجع
يعني ايه شو هي هذه خطوه الى التقسيم خطوه
الى التقسيم بلا بلا شك بلا منازع طيب طيب
طيب خليني ارجع على لنقطه قبل ما بس
نجليها انت تقول فوضى وما فوضه وسلاح وما
سلاح طيب اول شيء الدكتور سمعته كم كم عدد
ال السلاح الموجود كم قطعه سلاح 22 22
مليون قطعه سلاح انت تعلم عندما وقف
القذافي على متحف السرايا الحمراء في
طرابلس وقال بالحرف الواحد انه سيحول
ليبيا الى نار وجمر اذا لم تتوقفوا عن
الثوره وسوف تندمون في يوم ما لم ينفع فيه
الندم وماذا فعل وقتها فتح كل المخازن كل
مخازن السلاح يعني قلوا لليبيين انتم
عانيت من ط من طغياني لمده 40 عام وس
اترككم الان تذبحون بعضكم البعض بالسلاح
الذي سا اوزعه الذي يحدث هو من مخلفات
القذافي من مخلفات الطاغيه
م لا لا رد لك عليها لاني انا لما افتح
افتح مخازن السلاح المفروض الثوار ياخذوا
السلاح الان اللي مستلم الدوله الليبيه هم
الثوار اين القذافي اين جماعه القذافي
يعني انت تريد رجل تحمله ميتا او حي
سلبياتك انتم اخذتم السلاح الجماعات
الثائره عندها السلاح له لماذا تتقاتل
لماذا تدخل طرابلس تولي عليه يا رجل رصاص
يوم جم الاباح من البورح خليك شويه لماذا
تتقاتلون القذافي ذهب القذافي فتح المخازن
لماذا انتم تتقاتلون بها الان رد لي عليكم
انا ذكرت ان ليست هناك اي جبهه مستعره في
ليبيا هذا شي من يقاتل من اذا ليست هناك
وهذه الاخبار التي نسمعها يوميا الابار
العج ليست هناك جبهه مشتعله بمعنى جبهه
قتال مشتعله تستمر من
الصباح هي عباره احيانا مناوشات واحيانا
اسبابها يعني قد يكون يعني بسيط جدا وتحل
انا اقول لك يعني امس في بنغازي حدث
اشتباك في عشيه وضحاه خلال ساعات دقائق
انتهى كل الموضوع لكن انا صراحه سارجع الى
قضيه الفيدراليه في نقطه سريعه بس يعني بس
لا لا بسرعه بدون الفيدراليه الفيدراليه
باختصار نظام لا هي نظام لا مركزي فقط
كنظام تطم الليبيين انه ليبيا لن تنفصل لن
تنفصل باذنه تعالى وهذا نراهن عليه ويراهن
عليه الشعب الليبي الشيء الاخر بالنسبه
الىل التقاتل ليس هناك اي تقاتل في تحدث
بعض الاشتباكات البسيطه جدا بين بعض
المناطق او بين بعض الاشخاص ويتم حلها
وراها الى ابعد الحدود وليس هناك بالنسبه
الىى السلاح قبل الاسبوع هذا عند تمت
محاكمه بوزيد دورده وهو رئيس الاستخبارات
الليبي في اثناء مرافعته يقول بالحرف
الواحد هو قام بدعم جهه ماء في ليبيا في
المنطقه الغربيه تحديدا يعني حتى لا نذكر
اسماء احتراما للناس قام بدعمها واعطائها
السلاح قال لهم حتى تجابه الناس لما تحمل
سلاح وتدخلوا في امور فيها اشتباك وفيها
الى غير ذلك هذا الكلام منصوص وهذا الامر
يعني يعني اسمح لي يعني هو اهل مكه ادر
بشعابها صراحه يعني نحن كنا نتمنى يعني
انلا يدخل في هذه الامور لان في بعض
الجزئيات لا يعلم بها يعني اسمح لي لو لو
ننتقل حتى الى يعني هل تريد ان تقول ان
خالد عمر بن جقه يردد ببغائي ما يسمعه في
الاعلام المضخم ل انا ذكرت انه اعلامي
وليس بسياسي هذه ينبغي ان تعلم ومن
القواعد السياسيه ان السياسي لا يهتم
بالفعل ولا رده الفعل وانما يهتم بمنطق
الفعل ل معلومات
الر ليست لديه اي شي هو رجل
اعلامي انا يعني ساتيك في المعلومات اولا
بالنسبه دعنا نتكلم اسمحلي بس هو قال ليست
هناك دوله هذه مهمه صراحه وهذه مغ السلا ذ
نق نقطه خالد اعود الى الان اهم نقطه يعني
كل من يكره ليبيا او يكره العهد الجديد في
ليبيا او يحن الى ايام الطغيان الخوالي
يدندن على نغمه العنف في ليبيا دقيقه
العنف في ليبيا العنف في ليبيا والقتال في
ليبيا والسلاح في ليبيا والوضع الامني
المتدهور هذا هو العنوان الرئيسي في ليبيا
صح ولا لا الرجل من قادم من ليبيا يقول لك
عباره عن مناوشات بسيطه لا ترقى الى
مواجهه وليس هناك جبهات تتقاتل هي عباره
عن اشياء يوميه تحدث وتنتهي بين ليله
وضحاها هذه هي النقطه دكتور نحن على هذه
نحن في هذا البرنامج لنوضح الامور للمشاهد
للمشاهد وحتى ندخل في المتاهات
هذه ل لا دع لا دعنا نثبت امر ليس هناك
فصل بين ما هو اعلامي وسياسي اولا الكارثه
اللي اعملت في ليبيا من اساسها انه استعنت
بجماعات مثل جليل وغيره وكذا جزء من
النظام فحولته الى جزء من حكام ثانيين
وهذه كارثه سياسيه بكل مقاييس اللي حاصل
في الوطن العربي وليس في ليبيا ككل دكتور
هو مش لانني من السياسي لاننا نجاهر بقول
حق وتريدون ان تاخذون الى مزيد من المازق
والدماء بمعنى انه الحاكم العربي سببه
الكارث ليس قراراته فقط سببه مجموعاته
التي تحول حوله سواء كان هذا حاكما او
صاحب مؤسسه اعلاميه او صاحب مركز بحثي او
صاحب دوله لماذا لان المجموعات التي حوله
تقول له ما يريد ان يقوله عديله الدكتور
يعني
يعني يكون خوف لا لا لا خوف خوف لان
الدكتور يقول يقول الان يعني بما فيها من
دماء ليبيا انه السياسيين في ليبيا لكي
يرضوا في سياق معين سواء كان سياق
ايديولوجي سياق جماعي يبرر لهم سوء العمل
يا اخي سو في سوء عمل في كارثه حقيقيه في
ليبيا في ادماء ل تريد ان تقول
لناس دكتور لا لا لا مالهاش علاقه
بالقذافي مالهاش علاقه بال مالهاش علاقه
لا ترحم القفي ترحم مع القذافي تحلم بانها
تعود الايامه يا رجل تحلم مش ترحم تحلم
انها تعود الايامه لان الشعوب
هذ ما علينا ما علينا انت دكتور انت دكتور
خريج نظام القذافي ام
ستخر الليبيين والف الليبيين في السلطه
الان زيدان وغيره
تعلم المكله ان الحاكم العربي ا ت دكتور
الحاكم مش طاغيه هذا مصطلح قراني وعلينا
انت لا لا لا الحاكم العربي الحاكم العربي
لان لاننا خرجنا من عهد استعمار جهلا
الحاكم العربي حينما يعلم شعبه ويثقف
ويساهم معه في التطوير والتنوير والبناء
يتمرد عليه شعبه لصالح قوى خارجيه او
يقتله في مزاد عام لانه يقابل جز يا رجل
انتم الان فئه مثقفه كل ليبيين يا رجل
انتم في ليبيا كنتم ثم مليون يخدمكم 4
مليون ياخذكم ثمانيه يا رجل كانوا معاي
الطلبه ليبيين انا في القاهره وفي غيرها
في اماكن ثانيه ياخذوا اعلى المنح يعني
انا انا مستغرب هذا الطرح يجب انه شيطن
الحاكم ليس ملاكا القذافي ولا غير القذافي
ولا زيدان ولا غيره ولا هو شيطان هو بشر
له اخطاء و غيرها اذا التغطيه على ما يحدث
في في القول تغطيه على ما يحث الان لا
بالضبط انت دكتور من حقك انك تهدا في
الامور وغير ولكن انت تكلم لي ب 22 قطعه
سلاح ه 22 مليون قطعه سلاح توجه لي انا
كخالد ولا ليك تتوجه داخل المجتمع الليبي
يا رجل اين هذه تصدر فيها ليبيا المالي
تصدر فيها المصر طيب اذا بس ناخذ كلمه
يعني لا يحلمون يترحمون على ايام القذافي
يا رجل الان هذه جزء من لعنه تع القذافي
اللي حاصل ال في جم جدا كيف بدي رد قوي ا
الليبيين عم يسمعوك الان بكره بوا علي انا
يلا اولا الليبيين يعني ليس هناك اي شخص
منهم يحلم بعوده الطاغيه او ايامه اسمح لي
اسمح لي اسمح لي انا لم اقاطعك صراحه يعني
اسمح لي وهذه حقيقه دامغه لا يزايد فيها
اي شخص نتيجه لما رايناه طيله 42 سنه من
التيه الممنهج ولا اقول يعني يعني شيء اخر
الشيء الاخر اللي يتكلم عليه الاستاذ
الفاضل هو لم تكن هناك اي دوله في ليبيا
لم تكن نحن لم ننقلب على دوله بل بالعكس
اول ما خرجت الناس قت كانت تقول نريد
اعاده بناء النظام والتق فها عبد الاله
بال جريز واكتبها في مقام ل نظام بناء
النظام الظام اسمحي النظام في ايام
القذافي اسمحلي انا ساتيك هذا جانب وثائق
ويكيليكس كلها تقول ان ابناء القذافي
يعتبرون مؤسسه النفط الليبيه بنكا خاصا
لهم القذافي يا اخي يعاني من ابنائه و ولا
يستطيع حتى اداره عائلته المفككه بعضهم
يتعارك على مصنع الكوكا كولا يعني حتى الى
درجه الامريكان في وثائق وكيليكس يخافون
من ماذا يخافون ان يكون هناك صراع حاد بين
ابناء القذافي نتمنى من لم يكن هناك د
اسمعني لا لا نتمنى من اهلنا في الجزائر
اللي اللي تاركين اسره الان القذافي المقب
هناك وحتى زوجه احد الابناء تتكلم نتمنى
الجنرالات يمنون علينا باخراجهم جنرالات
الجزائر جنرالات السكر والزيت والتجاره
والى غير ذلك والغاز يا دكتور انا لا اريد
ان افتح الجزائر لكن اعطيك معلومه 30
تقريبا حكومه شكلت في الجزائر و 200 او
300 وزير والجنرالات هم هم لمده تقريبا 30
سنه هذه الجنرالات الذين يحاولون كما
كانوا في ليبيا يحاولون تجين الشعوب والله
انهم لن يفلحوا اعود فاقول نتمنى من
الحكومه الجزائريه ان تمن علينا بتسليم
ابناء القذافي ابناء القذافي وخصوصا
هانيبال الذي متورط في الهيومن ترافيك
التجار بالبشر وفي التعذيب ومشكلته في سوخ
نقطه مهمه اذا انتم انتم لم تجدوا دوله لم
تجد دولج دوله نتكلم لك على المكاسب اليوم
ولله الحمد والمنه هات نشوف اولا كم هي
عمر الدوله فعليا
7722 بد المؤتمر الوطني العام لو اردنا ان
نتكلم بالارقام اول اجتماع في 1/8 من 1/8
الى الان سنه واربعه اشهر الحكومه
الموجوده الان تكونت متى تكونت في شهر
10/2012 الى الان سنه وشهرين المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء كسلطان تكلمت على التشريعيه
تكلمت على التنفيذيه السلطه القضائيه لم
تشتغل الا ست اشهر خوزيه اورتيجا يقول
ماذا يقول والله نتمنى احيانا الغرب فهم
اشياء لامعه يقول عمر الثوره لا يقل عن 15
سنه حتى تخرج لنا جيلا يمتطي هذه الثوره
الشيء الاخر يا دكتور تداول تداول سلمي
للسلطه انا اتحداه يسمي لي دوله عربيه لها
ثلاث رؤساء لها ثلاث حكماء وزراء نحن الان
مصطفى عبد الجليل اخذ الرايه وسلمها لشيخ
المين الدكتور محمد يوسف المقريف واخذ
الرايه وسلمها للامازيغ الحر اللي هو الان
اللي موجود الان وهو من مدينه زواره لا
اله الا ساذكر اسمه
مهم
لا المهم سلم الرايه وهذا يدل على اننا
لسنا حتى قبليين ننظر للامازيغ بانهم
ليبيون ولعلهم اكثر من الليبيون عندنا
ثلاث حكومات حكومه الدكتور محمود
جبريل نعم سلمها لعبد الرحيم الكبت وهو
عالم من علماء الطاقه والكهرباء وكان معه
مصطفى بوشاقور وهو عالم من علماء
النانوتكنولوجي نعم سلمها للمناضل علي
زيدان والقافله تستمر انا لا اتكلم على
اشخاص انا ادافع على مؤسسات داخل الدوله
عمرها متوسط عمرها سنه واحده خالد خالد بس
ب الشي الاخر اسمحلي نحن قضينا على يعني
اوسخ نظام وهو نظام الجمليات اللي كان
يسعى الى توريث الانظمه والى توريث ليبيا
وتسليمها في مشروع ليبيا الغد الى السيف
القذافي هذه هي انجازاتنا وت خل دقيقه انت
زلمه منطق وعلمي صح ولا لا الرجل يتحدث
ارقام يتحدث اسماء يتحدث يقول لك الان اي
ثوره في العالم بحاجه ل 15 عاما نحن
مشكلتنا العرب يعني بفكر الثوره مثل تيك
اواي اطلوب شويه كنتاكي وكان الله يحب
المحسنين وخلصنا الثوره دقيقه خليني اكملك
خليني اكمل لك 15 عاما 15 عاما خلال فتره
قصيره سنه وشوي كم حكومه كم مؤسسه كم كذا
مشكلتنا الان في العالم العربي كل من يقول
انه الربيع العربي تحول الى جهنم الذي ت
حولوا الى جهنم هم اعداء الثورات وان
الربيع غصب عن ابوه الربيع
وسيزر ق ما تشا قل ما تشا لانك انت
وامثالك والشارع اللي تحكي عنه تريد ان
تطيل عمر الفتنه وتريد فتنه ماشي بدي
اسالك انت من الجزائر انت من الجزائر انت
من الجزائر انت من الجزائر طيب انتم في
الجزائر كان عندكم ما يسمى بالعشر السوداء
سن دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه ع سنوات ع سنوات قتل
ودماء وتخريب وكذا وهذه الجزائر باقيه ليش
خايف على ليبيا ليش خايف على ليبيا جزئ
لان الدكتور كان يكلمك لان فيها جنرالات
خلوها باقيه لان فيها مؤسسه عسكريه خلوها
باقيه لان لانه لولا المؤسسه العسكريه
الجزائريه يا رجل اتق الله في
نفس انت عارف دائك للجيوش انت حر بس لا
تفرغ عني في الجزائر
بلا
عاين ر شوشه هذ
حر جابونا 6 ال
دايه خليك شيه يا سيدي
الجنرال تحكيله عن ليبيا عن ليبيا يا سيدي
لو يتحدث الرجل انه ما حدث في الجزئ
الجزائر لم تخرب لان لديها جنرالات لديها
مؤسسه عسكريه محترمه وقويه مش جنرالات
الرز والسكر والقمح والغاز والعلكه شو
اسمه اه انتم اين لديكم هذا الجنرالات
الجنرالات هو انتقال لما قال اتوا
بالاستقلال هو انتقال من الاستعمار الى
الاستحمار وهذا لا الاستحمار وهذا لا نريد
ان نقع فيه في ليبيا اي جنرالات يا يعني
تريد ان تدوسوا على المؤسسه العسكريه لا
لا لا نريد ان نكون مؤسسه عس عسكريه تحتفظ
بحمايه الدوله دستور الدوله تحمي الشعب
الى غير ذلك انا ساتكلم تك مقاه رز وقمح
ابد ساتكلم في في وثيقه لويكي ليكس غطاس
ليبي ايام القذافي في 2009 يرسل للتدريب
على الغوص في في ايطاليا لا يجيد السباحه
وزير الدفاع السوداني عندما سئل لماذا تم
ضرب بورسعيد قال لان الطائرات اتت بالليل
وكان صوت وكانت طافيه هذ جنرالات العرب
الذين نريد ندخل ب
الشي اللواء اح الحا ينقل شهادته عبر قناه
الجزيره يقول عندما تم القبض عليه في
السين بتهمه محاوله انقلاب ضد القذافي قال
اللي بلغ فينا احد الضباط وهو موجود الان
في ليبيا والحمد لله ان اعفي الشيء الاخر
قال يقول بان بعض الضباط وهم في التنظيم
يتم استقطابهم بحيث تتم الشهاده علينا
يعني يقولوا له تشهد على بسخر كثير
الموضوع بس خليني لا بدي اسالك طيب انت
قلت قبل قليل سؤال مهم قلت ش شيء مهم انه
اي ثوره في العالم بحاجه ل 15 عاما نعم كي
تنط طيب طيب لماذا لا نقول في الان ذاته
مشان خالد ما يفكر انه نحن ضده اه انه
لماذا لا نقول انه ليبيا قد تتجه نفس
الاتجاه اللي اتجهت افغانستان او الصومال
الصوماليون اسقطوا سياد بري في ال0 ماشي
ماشي اين هي الدوله الصوماليه بعد 13 سنه
اين هي الدوله الافغانيه بعد ان اسقط
المجاهدون الافغان نجيب الله وا والرجس
السوفيتي اين ذب تذابحوا يعني الان يحدث
في ليبيا الثوار الامس دقيقه الكثير من
الثوار هذه وصلتني الكثير من الثوار في
ليبيا الان لا يت يتصرفون كثوار كثيران
البعض يقول كيف ترد اولا اذا بلغ ما قلتين
لم يحمل الخبث هذه واضحه وينبغي ان تكون
معلومه وبعض بعض الاخطاء هي هي مغموره في
بحر حسناتهم دعنا الان نتكلم ب لغه
الارقام ما ينفعش الا الارقام الاحصائيات
تقول وزير العمل في ليبيا في 2013 يقول ان
البطاله في ليبيا كانت 12% في 2011 21%
تقرير التنميه ل 2013 ليبيا في المرتبه 64
الجزائر
93 مجله الايكونوميست في في في اثنين
الجزائر 93 نعم
93 نعم نعم مجله الاكون هذا تقرير تقرير
في الاكون تقول نمو في ليبيا سيكون مدعوما
باعاده اعمار البلاد في اعقاب سقوط
القذافي وستصل نسبه النمو 23% النمو
الناتج المحلي 8.8 دعنا نتكلم على معدل
الفرد او معدل دخل الفرد في ليبيا كان 14
1420 اليوم ولله الحمد والمله والمنه
14884 دكتور اذا
كان النفط
الان
ا يا خالد يا خالد خلينا شوي الرجل الرجل
يقتبس من الايكونومست هي اهم مجله
اقتصاديه في العالم
ت الواقع انت امام النفط الليبي قاعد
يتصدر هذه الايام انت شايفه للنفط الليبي
شاف ارجع القنوات الليبيه ارجع الجرائد
الليبيه
الاخبار هذا
الامر هناك معدل للسيوله في ليبيا ولله
الحمد بس فقط الاموال اللي الخارجيه
تقريبا 200 مليار هذه من غير اموال محجوز
عليها ومن غير اموال سيتم ادخالها الان
نسعى ونتمنى كما تتحدث معنا الان نتمنى ان
تدافع عن حقوقنا 77 مليار موجوده في مصر
ونحاول استرجاعها من ازلام القذافي
الموجودين هناك 30 30 مليار فقط طيب تكلم
اكتب مقال في هذا الامر في الاهرام لماذا
لا تتكلم دافع عن حقوقنا عن ارزاقنا دافع
عن عن المال دافع عن الحق العام لماذا لا
تدافع عن هذه الامور وت 30 مليار هذه
الشفافيه في ليبيا 30 مليار للقذافي
اخفاها قذافي الدم في عقارات وبنوك وشركات
مصريه ولعل حتى البعض منها وهمي وهذه مجله
الروز يوسف هذا هذا الدخل
الليبيين هناك شيء هناك احتياط لا ننسى ان
هناك
احتياط يتم احيانا استخدامه في حالات
الطوار ماشي خالد طيب الرجل بس دقيقه نعود
هل كانت ليبيا لتحقق هذه الارقام حسب
الايكونومست حسب الايكونومست لو لم تكن
ليبيا مستقره لو كانت فعلا ليبيا على كف
عفريت امنيا وست لو كانت على كف عفريت لما
حققت ذيك انت هل تراها مستقره انت انت انت
كفيس القا انا
استقر انا بدك جوابي انا بدي اسالك اياه
طيب بدي اسالك يا اخي خليني اسالك يا سيدي
يا سيدي عندما عندما يرث الشعب الليبي
بلدا بلا جيش بلا شرطه
غير
مست لما يكون عندك جيش وشرطه انت تعيد
البنا من الاول لا ده انت كان عندك شرطه
ودمر كانت الشرطه عن كتائب القذافي كتائب
القرف تبقولي
سيدي انت بتريد الهرو
الواقع غيرك
الوا تم
الق مسح
ليبيا اكبر د عند 200 ال مسلح يعلم الواقع
في ليبيا اخي طيب خالد بس دقيقه بس دقيقه
انا بدي اسالك سؤال وصل محمد محيسن يسالك
مثلا بس اسالك سؤال صغير انت تقوللي انه
قبل كم
يوم اهل طرابلس هجموا على بعض الميليشيات
ووقعت اصابات وما بعرف شوذا ماش بطرابلس
طيب لماذا لا ننظر الى مثل هذه الاحداث من
وجهه نظر ايجابيه في الماضي الشعب الليبي
عندما كان يمر من جنب جهاز مخابرات بيسوى
صرماي هو اللي فيه كان كان لا يستطيع ان
ينظر الى الاجهزه الشعب الليبي الان
يستطيع يستطيع ان يمسح الارض باكبر رجل
مخابرات يا يا فرحتي ان يمسح ارجع الدوله
غير موجوده يا فرحتي والدوله غير موجوده
يا اخي انا اريد دوله انت تريد قانون دوله
انت انا اريد دوله دوله دذ مؤسسات
الوله ليست مؤسسات لا يا
اخي اخي وزير رئيس وزراء مخطوف الان من
جماعات مخوف ر رجل دوله غ نهايا خلي خلي
لا لا لا دقيقه خالد خالد خالد قال يعني
هل يعقل ان البعض يتفاخر باننا هجمنا على
الشرطه وعلى الامن وعلى الجيش هذه هي غياب
دوله ليس هناك جيش وشرطه يا دكتور فيصل لا
يعرف الواقع في ليبيا حتى عندما قال خطف
رئيس الوزراء ويلوم الثوار الذين اخرجوهم
الثوار ينبغي ان
ينصف ينبغي ان ينصف الثوار اسمحلي انا
ينبغي ان يتم نصفه يا اخي هو يقول الان ان
الوضع مريب طيب ما رايك يا اخي قبل
اسبوعين تقريبا بعض شركات الدول العربيه
اوقفت الطيران الى ليبيا البريتش رويز
تزيد من الرحلات الى طرابلس رقب هذا الامر
لا تستطيع ان ترقبه الا ان تقول ان هناك
استقرار في ليبيا مشهود بعض الطائرات او
الشركات او الانظمه تخاف من حقها ماشي بس
خليني اسالك سؤال صغير سؤال صغير دكتور
دكتور انت تعلم انت تعلم ان القذافي صدع
راسنا على مدى اكثر من 40 سنه وهو يتشدق
بالشرعيه الثوريه الفاتح من سبتمبر الفاتح
نص فلوس ليبيا راحت على الاحتفال بالشرعيه
الثوريه لدينا الان مليون قذافي يريدون ان
يعيدوا نفس نفس التراث ليس ليس هناك اي
ليس هناك اي مليون بل بالعكس الشباب الان
بعضهم يندمج في في في بعد قرار 614 و613
يندمج في الجيش والشرطه الذين رايناهم
الاسبوع الماضي نزلوا الى شوارع في طرابلس
وفي غيرها معظمهم من الثوار ودخلوا في في
تدريب في السودان ودخلوا في تدريب داخلي
وبدوا يندمجون في هذه الامور فقط انا اقول
ه هذه مهمه هناك من يسعى الى تحطيم الثوره
الليبيه مستخدما طريقين اثنين اولا هدم
المرتكزات هذه الثوره الوحده الوطنيه
العدل اللحمه الوطنيه ال
ادا ساقول لك من ساقول لك من الاستراتيجيه
الاخرى هي استراتيجيه الحفر يحاولون ان
يحفرون ويصلون في ناس كانوا منبطحين مع
ايام القذافي الان جواب على الاستاذ وهو
مهم الاستاذ علي زيدان توجه في اخر رحله
الى مصر ماذا كانت اجنده هذه الزياره احد
الاجندات كان يتكلم مع الحكومه المصريه
على ازلام القذافي الموجودين هناك والذين
يملكون 77 مليار معظم الاموال التي موجوده
عند الازلام ومنهم حتى اللي في الجزائر
ونتمنى من اهلنا في الجزائر يتم تسليم
تسليمهم الحكومه الليبيه في النيجر في
كثير من الدول الان يحاولون اسمعني بس
تنظيم صفوفهم ويحاولون شراء ويحاولون يا
اخي اداء الث اكيد اعداء الثوره لا شك في
ثوار هذول اللي الثوار يا اخي هذ ليس
الثوار لنعلم ان السجون ايام القذافي كلها
تم تسليحها وفتحت المجرمين اللي كانوا
محكوم عليهم بالمخدرات والان نعاني منها
وغيرها اصبحت ليبيا الان بسببهم سوق
للمخدرات سوق للجريمه سوق حتى للهوم
ترافيك التجار بالبشر يا اخي هناك حبه حتى
حتى نربط مع الازلام في الخارج هناك حبه
مخدر تباع 50 دولار سعرها الاساسي في
ليبيا ب 10 دولار لماذا من يدفع الفارق
اولئك الذين يعني يجنحون على اموال الشعب
الليبي في خارج ليبيا في مصر والجزائر وفي
دول اخرى كثيره يعني الجزائر خايف يصير
فيها نفس الشيء اكيد الان الان يا اخي من
اولا نحن نقول حتى نصحح للدكتور لان بدري
ذكرها نحن نعيش في حقبه ما بعد
الايديولوجيات الايديولوجيات كلها صدقت
سقطت الدكاليه كلها سقطت الان ليس هناك
مشروع الا مشروع التغيير ومشروع الاسقاط
وكما يقول هنس يقول بان لكل ثوره خصوصيه
وتراكم وان يكون ان يكون مالها النصر هذه
الثلاث اشياء مهمه جدا كل ثوره تصنع نفسها
حسب السياق السوسيولوجي وحسب السياق الا
انثولوجي اللي عندها اما غير ذلك فلا
ينبغي ثم يا اخي لماذا ينعكس المثقفين
وينعزل عن الحراك الاجتماعي مثل الاستاذ
خالد يترك يترك الشعوب تتحرك لانهم لان
معظم المثقفين حقيقه وللاسف لم يقودوا
التغيير الذين قادوا التغيير اليوم هم
الشعوب وينبغي احترام اراده الشعوب ومنهم
الشعب الليبي اليوم يا دكتور فيصل
65% من الشعوب العربيه اذا رايناها كلها
حملها التغيير مصر تونس ليبيا اليمن سوريا
في الطريق الى غير ذلك خمس دول تقريبا 65%
من الشعوب لا شك جنرالات الجزائر يخافون
من هذا الامر لان سيوقف مضاجعهم ونحن نعلم
حتى بل بل انا اقول لك معلومه حتى حتى
عائله القدافي يا دكتور فيصل لم تدخل الى
الاراضي الجزائريه وانما كانت في الاراضي
الليبيه وتم احضارهم داخل الاراضي الليبيه
وادخالهم الى الجزائر هذه معلومه ينبغي ان
يعلمها جنرالات الجزائر طيب
شي نحترم نحن نحترم الجزائر وعندنا
استراتيجيه في العلاقات الدوليه هو كيف
تحول من العدو حليف استراتيجي اول ما تولى
علي زيدان زار كل دول الطوق زارها دوله
دوله وتكلم معهم وتكلم عن عن عن المخاطر
اللي تواجه ليبيا في اطار تعاون مشترك وفي
صداقات ولكن للاسف هناك الى الان حكومات
تظن ان ليبيا مثل ايام القذافي البقر
الحلوب الان هناك علاقات مشتركه ومصالح
مشتركه ينبغي توجيه النظر اليها هذا الذي
اريد ان اوصل للناس جميل جدا خالد بس بس
دقيقه طيب انا بس بدي اسالك سؤال انا
اليوم عملت استفتاء على الفيسبوك وعلى
تويتر يعني كان اللي مشتركين فيه تقريبا
شي 4 مليون اه يعني يجيني 200 واحد يقول
لي من ليبيا الوضع في ليبيا الان افضل ولا
واحد قال ب 10000 مره يقول لي الوضع في
ليبيا افضل بف مره ونحن رغم كل ما اسينا
في ليبيا نحن في في في في في عز في خير
يجيني طبيب ليبي يقول لي يا رجل على الاقل
انا كنت اشتغل في الخارج عندما ادخل مطار
ليبيا كنت اموت من الرعب لانني ساختفي
الان ندخل ونخرج بكل عزه
نفس اخي العزيز اخي العزيز قاعد تخلط في
الامور من قاللك ان الوضع في ليبيا
سابقا احسن من الان الوضع سي قبل ش قم
جايلك
جا دعني اكملك دعني اكملك بس انت مش
تمسكني يا فيصلب شوف انا جايك للنهايه
الوضع كان سي جز قطريات منن وضع عربي عام
وغيرها خلاص الوضع الان اسوا يعني يعني
يعني الدكتور اخ اطاك معلومات انت ما عندك
غير تقلي اسوا هو عم يعطيك ارقام اي ارقام
تتكلم اي ارقام
تتكلم علاقه بالكون ل هي علاقه بنفك غير
موزع
اليوم ليس كل النفط غير موزع يا اخي ليس
كل النفط بعض المواني فق اخي جاي من ليبيا
وان عندي
ع ليست كل المواني يا اخي هذه هيحه هناك
مواني في الرض هناك يا اخي خط انبو خط خط
يعني نفطي من ترابلس الى ايطاليا يا اخي
دتور دور دكتور دكتور لانك انت دخلت لست
دكتور انا لست مدافعا على وضع سي اريده في
ليبيا ولا انت ايضا محامي شرعي على الشعب
الليبي حتى لا نخلط الامور لانك تليتلي من
حقك تعبر العت فيها محامي وت فيها فيصل
محامي الحقيقه وما فيها ان هناك وضع سيء
انت تريد ان تروه واقع اخر بما فيه من قتل
بما فيه من انهيار للدوله بما فيه تحول
ليبيا الى فيدراليه بما فيه كذا بما فيه
سوع علاقات مع الجوار اللي تتكلم عليها مع
من
الجوار
ليعكس لي هناك اي علاق الوضع في مالي
وغيرها طرف فيه ليبيا ط ليس جوار ومالي
بعيده لا اسمحلي لا
هذ خال مالي مالي بعيده
جدا انا عارف انا
عار ال
مجرم 20 الف مجرم في ليبيا انا ذكرت
يتاجرون في المخدرات يتاجرون في الاتجار
بالبشر ومن ضمنها
الاتجار باخر معنا دقيقه بنص دقيقه ماذا
تريد ان
تقول ماشي ماشي بس بدقيقه ماذا
تقول لا لا بس لا بس بدي اسالك سؤال توجه
انت من ليبيا الان كل الذين يخوفون الشعوب
من الثورات يقول لهم شوفوا ليبيا خربت شو
ليبيا بدا تنفصل ماذا تقول مش لليبيين
للشعوب العربيه الثائره هؤلاء هؤلاء
يخافون من الثوره ونحن نخاف على الثوره
ايه والشعوب الثائره ماذا تقول لهاب الث
نقول لها كملي والطريق ليست فييه عوده كما
قال لواء عبد الفتاح يونس قال عندما سئل
ان ان ان اخرج له صور النظام القذافي بانه
مع القذافي قال لهم ليست هناك عوده نحن
لسنا في سوق السكراب او بيع رابش او بيع
خرده وانما نحن في ثوره وفي تغيير
والمسيره ستمضي باذنه تعالى وسنقوم مؤسسات
الدوله الان عندنا تنفيذيه
وتشريع بيض صنائعنا سود وقائعنا حمر
مواضينا خضر مرابعنا هذا هو الذي سيكون
باذنه تعالى خضر مرابعنا وانا ادعوك يا
استاذ خالد ان تزور ليبيا باذن
تعال انته
الوقت
ماينتهي اسمع انت تتكلم عن الطواغيت هناك
طواغيت يتولد جدد باسم الثورات خلاص
ينوبون منابل حكام
القور الكرام لم يبق لنا لم يبقى لنا نشكر
ضيفي السيد خالد عمر بن جقه والسيد خالد
الورفلي نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين اه هاه فيصل قاسم يحييكم من
الدوحه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء